he got my mom's leg racer and he shaved
his whole head
he's shaking his heart
i welcome you man listen quick plug
red bubble yeah they don't sponsor the
podcast i know obviously we
we're big now second biggest podcast on
the planet
joe rogan's still peaking but he's
dropping like we're climbing
we're climbing up the thing we've got
our own studio we're chasing the thing
so let me do a quick plug again they
don't sponsor the channel
you would assume anything i say now
we're getting paid to say because we
make
go up hunter x hunter
top when i wore this last time bear man
were dropping
comments i was impressed well done yeah
you might notice the hunter artwork here
sir
so yeah anime fans we see you guys
speaking of certificate of anime fans as
well when we record when we ask for
recommendations like
three four five episodes ago coming when
it was granted you don't know the
calibre of stuff you've watched by a lot
of the stuff man
come on man that's family
listen i appreciate the effort you man
are talking to us like we're scrubs
you thought oh we've seen little naruto
in it therefore are these mom might see
now so i said they're like anime
listen watch dance i was almost
embarrassed by the amount of stuff
every single comment i've seen all of it
i've seen all of it you man i've been
watching anime since i was 16 i'm 29
years of age from
i've been watching anime since i was 18.
bro i've been watching anime for a very
long time so if you men are going to
drop
death note that's the first anime i
watched
fam these men are dropping yeah yeah
yeah watch death note
my hero academia i'm thinking
one punch man one punch man come on
we've seen these
bruh someone said hunter make sunset use
that i've seen that
twice i was like so i had to comment
that one i was thinking the money you
manage embarrassing yourself
a lot of people did recommend the um jiu
jitsu um kaizen which we've both started
so
that's the thing actually not even to
cast people ratings for
recommended jiu-jitsu kaisen but also
the fact that you recommended an anime
that only has
three episodes out four now
oh actually no by the time this comes
out probably five or six yeah but when
when when the when the comment dropped
they had three episodes
no two two two episodes when that
comment came out we are
two epis they had two episodes out don't
you
dare recommend a punchy juicy anime
that's got
two episodes fam how
dare you i need a season i need a whole
seat because the first time we asked for
recommendations
someone gave us vin lan saga and you
watched it i've seen that saga
and you recommend it to me then i
watched it i loved it i watched it
sick villa saga was gang so that's
that's a recommendation it's got a
catalogue
imagine recommending me a podcast that's
got two episodes what's the point
i will swing you what's the point i'm up
to date today
what's the point and i even said in the
episode i started one piece because it's
got
a thousand episodes i need mana
dropping jiu-jitsu kaiser that's
embarrassing no but thank you yeah
also thank you because it's still dope
test me
you know what i mean i'm asking for a
test yeah but um
yeah yeah have you got you got a fun
fact yeah yeah yeah
that was a funny segue um
so as i've been on this animal tip for a
minute
um did you know that female fish will
fake orgasms to trick males into
thinking they've successfully mated
they will then swim and way to find a
better partner
i'll read that again that's toxic female
fish
will fake an orgasm to trick males in to
think if they're successfully mated
they will then swim away to find a
better
partner how dare you i didn't know human
beings were so close to fish
[Music]
i didn't know these hoes were so close
to fish
that's hurt my feelings cause because
that's what these men do every day
that's disgusting behavior that's
disgusting behavior
at least i know it's not these man's
fault at least i know it's not women's
fault that they do that's in their dna
it's in there
it's in their jeans it's been there
they're they're succubus
they're unholy that's disgraceful
behavior
that's disgraceful behavior your eyes
widened
i was disgusted i was disgusted because
it
resonates with me personally
boundaries it's obviously a your man got
scott piper it doesn't resonate with me
personally
but um i'm playing but speaking of
playing
this is a while back now the do you
remember the pic
i showed you i was wearing these shorts
yeah i know what you're gonna say i
think so the screenshotting
the screenshot yeah so for context
one fan was watching the pod
i'm so happy only one person actually to
be fair
probably many people maybe bear people
clocked it
but only one person had the goal to send
it to me
literally one woman sent it to me and i
was sitting this is in this is back when
we didn't have a studio back at
the old days the old days this is the
season beginning of season two
i was sitting like this leg edge up
comfy
my piece was edge up in the thing
my piece was friction up in these shorts
i had no clue one thing
she sent me a screenshot of it it was
clear
as day people like people are now going
to try and go back and travel yeah
they're going to i'm not going to say
what episode it was
i would all i'll say is that i like the
tools looking healthy
don't ask me that question answer as a
man don't ask me that
i'll take your silence as a firm yes
don't ask me that question now obviously
your boy still was looking health
um it was it was embarrassing it was
a clear silhouette do you know what i
mean
it was like the um
when girls fascinate faster fantasize at
all is the word fantasizing looking for
yeah when they fantasize about guys
wearing uh greyjoy
joggers it was great yoga's times a
million
you could see everything each individual
testy
the shaft and the balance the whole
thing cuz
you can see every when she's sending to
me i wasn't even embarrassed i laughed
i was in the gym and i saw it i was
howling
because i was like how is there so much
intricate detail
on your tv firm i knew the camera was
fresh but [ __ ] no
um but anyway yeah i don't even know how
i got into that but um
yeah that these fish need to stop that
these fish need to stop
all of that that's jokes um i've got a
cheeky fancy
sweater yeah all right cool i'm here for
it
i'm not going to say his name but he
said yo um x y and zed
i've been following your podcast for
long now and i actually love it i've
been plugging you to all my snap
i've been plugging on my snap for like
two months because it's so good i know
that podcast
i know that on the podcast you give
advice to people and i'm in a sticky
situation
and if you can help me out that would be
mad so basically
i've been texting this girl for time now
and we've been
mates since day one of secondary school
i'm now in sixth form
i've been interested in her for time
i've been interested in her for time now
and only in the last two
ish weeks she's actually given me some
of her time to get to know her
she said she wants to see how things
went so we hung out a few times alone
with other mates as well last night we
slept around my mates after
drinking that we ended up alone at one
point and we got off
i've had this message ah okay okay did
you reply no
okay i feel because i feel like the last
three episodes i've been like no
reply what was that yeah yeah we got off
i remember
i remember because i had to go off i
said i ain't saying i know this guy's
english or
australian i've i haven't heard the word
got off
in years we ended up alone at one point
and got off for the rest of the night
whenever we were alone we were all over
each other and then we shared a bed
bits were done hands went mad someone
got on top etc
that dry hump and man said hands
went mad my guy
listen that teenage fresh fresh
someone got on top that rub rub
that denim on denim listen
my tool uh next morning she didn't even
look at me
next day i text her saying that i don't
know what i did and she told me she
wasn't into me even though she was all
over me the night before
i don't know what ron what went wrong
help
so my first reply was actually let me
know what you're thinking about
all right so overview um i've known this
girl for time they've been mates
since day one of secondary school
they're now in six one together for the
past two weeks
they've been vibing a bit more went to a
shrubs went to a little house party
they got left alone madness happened he
squeezed a bit of tea
did a bit of dry hump next day she
locked man off
what are you saying i remember this i
i i literally remember this message and
for some reason it connected with a part
of me
when someone told me back a day that
women
mature faster than men
and i always took that as as a physical
sense because i know women hit puberty
before guys
and i always thought that was like a
physical thing because obviously as a
as a human being you can you're never
gonna accept the fact that someone will
re
mature emotionally or mentally faster
than you do
you just assume you're the [ __ ] what
maybe i do maybe i'm a narcissist but
i i never back then would ever assume
that someone matured faster
than i did and obviously in this day and
age as
a grown man i understand that certain
women are just out for the pipe
and they will use and abuse in the
methods that they see fit
yeah to get what they want yeah and um
when i read this message
that hit me like
i feel like that obviously he's not
in the position that we're in yeah
because to me
at the age that i'm at that's clear as
day yeah
you go had a brethren listen listen
listen right this is the way
i'm gonna tell you in a 29 year old
man's perspective
and you can dissect it as you will as a
20 year old
is a 29 year old man
if i has a if i have a female friend
platonic
we get a few drinks down us and we're in
a house party
and there's a free room and she's got no
prospects
that are currently in the building
i can guarantee you she's gonna take
your boy to the room
and we're gonna hands as you say are
gonna go mad
listen cause hands are gonna do nuts
and we're gonna some and i guarantee you
someone's getting on top
and if we're lucky there may be a slop
top in there as well
and then i bet you money cuz when
everyone's sober
i won't hear from her the next day
so the way i see if you put yourself in
an older man's body
you'll understand exactly what's going
on and you won't
i promise you you won't be messaging her
saying i don't know what happened
wrong you'll be saying thank you
thank you for the opportunity
so this was a win for me this was just a
nightfall yeah yeah
yeah yeah you see that yeah that's so
fun for me this was just a night for her
this was just an evening so when you get
older
and you get older and you look back at
this if this is the case
this is normal behavior for adults
and this is what i talked about the
maturity thing this is how adults
conduct themselves
they have a few drinks as on behalf of
women obviously i'm not a woman but i
have been in the game long enough don't
know how these men act
they act up when you've got a few drinks
in your system
your pineal gland axiax different
one said the pineal gland the frontal
lobe
who's mad he moves mad and you go a bit
archaic and you just want the closest
thing
be it be it tall you want the closest
thing in proximity
and if you've been friends with someone
for a very long time you find them
moderately attractive
you're comfortable you're comfortable
you're in a house party and there's a
three bedroom
big man i promise you're [ __ ] i
promise you you're having
intercourse 100 so and you're not
talking the next day
and i you can't make eye contact the
next day it's awkward
because you you gave in to your primal
desires
as every man would as every woman would
and now you can't face the other person
you can't go back to that friendship
thing as it was before
it's not a change on the younger flex
one of you is bound to catch feelings
maybe if there's a uh inter-gender
relationship friendship into gender
friendship
may is there's potential that one of you
had feelings
already already from the sounds of it my
man had feelings already
he tried to say we've been cool for
years clearly you you fancy yeah
from the she was she was rubbing tall
and all of a sudden you're lost
so you had feelings already you fancier
yeah yeah yeah
so being fancy you know if you put your
mind the way i would resolve this thing
put your mind
in the body of our older man obviously
you haven't had the experience of our
order my back
if you've listened to this podcast long
enough you understand how these things
go
your girl was horny she saw the closest
target
she drapes you to the closest free room
hands went mad
someone got on top the next day she
carried on with her life with her life
kept
and you thought your life had changed
like i said to you before
it was a night for her whereas you
thought it was a win it was just a night
first you thought it was a game
changer you thought it was a buzzer b
she was a bit loose and frisky cause
that's all it was
and the only difference is she hit
puberty the year before you did i said
she entered the game before you she's
got one year experience she's got one
more year's experience
all it took was a 365 and the game is
different
her different is different fam her hp is
up up so it's it's hard to hear
but fam you've got the game backwards
right now so
all i can see is that you've got the
game backwards like she
she she wanted saturn she secured it and
she didn't know
at the end there she's still young she
didn't know how to deal with the
consequences the next day
and the first thing that came to her
head was to lock you off i mean i owe
this [ __ ]
i may ignore this ignore him because i
can't face the shame of
what i have and i'm fine with ignoring
him that's it stop
that's how he's gonna move on and i
promise you big man next house party
if you don't act like a simp you're
gonna be calm
you've patted yourself consistent palm
yeah rugs from from here on there no no
if you don't don't beg ruin it ruin it
don't don't pay it as soon as you see
her again don't beg it
yeah no more it is what did i do thing
nothing only just rolling in there like
you're not even
not even like faster you can't you're
not even fuss to see her
yeah just just move because that way
she's going to be like okay he knows
he knows their game knows the game he's
educated now i've taught him the ropes
i've shown him the ting
we can go again come to the room she's
going to drop you a message like i'm
upstairs
round two question mark that's just
spanish question mark
let me go on top next time denims are
coming off
off these live this day i'm almost skin
on skin this time
leave your hands where they are my g
play the game right play the game right
benefit you in the long run
it's just calm you're benefiting along
because this short term thing you're
feeling now
it doesn't last long trust me it doesn't
last long it literally doesn't
and i've said this time and time again
but i know it's impossible to understand
when you're in this when you're
when you're in it it's hard to but
literally and this is something that
your parents say like oh love comes and
goes and all this stuff
and when you're a kid you're like [ __ ]
off brother you don't know what i'm
going through going through your heart
promise you cause if anyone knows
heartache it's these man
we've been free and i promise you it's
mine it's minor now it's nothing but you
have to firm it
yeah and if you firm it correctly you
can pattern yourself some pum
yeah from the next year and get yourself
some experience the experience that i
never had
and hey we move in it yeah mom but
don't ruin it don't please don't really
don't ruin it
you basically gave a full detailed
experience which i love
i'm just gonna give you the i'm
literally gonna say what i said to him
i was like laugh the [ __ ] out loud
quotation marks bits were done hands
were mad that's the funniest thing i've
ever heard
and i was like but that all sounds like
a huge mind [ __ ] not gonna like best
advice move the [ __ ] on you clearly in
some social
you're clearly in the same social group
of some sort
so she'll notice once you've pulled away
[ __ ] hate when you pull away the
balls in her court
grab that back basically exactly what we
just said that's also true as well
give it up shoulder let him know it's
mine now what's the
miner a little dry home you think man's
going to be gas
because the ball's in her court now
leave the ball in her court like
she's she's giving you the segue she
wanted to know if you confirm it
if you confirm a little dry hump she
wants to know if you're ready for more
for the reason these times your texts
are my god like what did i do what did i
do why are you ignoring me text me back
you need to lock that off immediately
give it a cold shoulder
and be like dry home what's that what is
that what's a wednesday thing
i want a saturday night thing and drapes
those levi's
off come let's party uh
you want a real house party come let's
fam i've got a question for you oh hit
me
do you have or do you remember your
worst
experience with a barber do you know
what's mad about that question you just
asked me because i was in the barbers
not too long ago
and my train was fine obviously but i
went
it was a sunday and it was just i was
the only customer in
and then another breath came in and he
was like
oh is that my man here i don't think he
missed my workshop there's two guys i
only go to
the main the guy that owns it and
another brother so i
go into the other bedroom on sunday
because the guys that owns it is always
off on a sunday right
always he's the boss man he's gonna take
sunday off he was off
so the my man that the new customer that
came in must not have patented or
clocked the thing that he doesn't come
on sunday is the owner so he's like oh
is this guy and he was pointing at the
owner's seat is this guy in
he's like no he's off today meanwhile
i'm getting my haircut minding my own
business but i'm just listening to this
so he's now like oh because i need to
get a good trim because the last guy
that did my trip [ __ ] my hair up
and he like pushed this thing back here
and this that there and this that there
he was speaking together he was speaking
together
the counter like he did it yeah do you
know what i mean yeah so man has backs
against the wall now yeah
so defensive the customer asked him can
you cut my hair
this is a receptionist yeah he was all
the guy at the counter was a barber but
he was chilling
he was just happy because he had no
customers yeah
so the new customer pointed at me and
said can you cut my hair
the pressure if i was that if i was
dealing with that
because because that made me think
that's bravado but
he also has the right to say that
because i'm paying you to do something
for me
but i've never opened a shop with bare
man in it
i expect every man to be able to do the
same job bare minimum that's the bare
minimum
whether you're doing styles on that
that's what irrelevant the bearing is
you have to do a bagging trim
bare minimum so it was like and then he
pointed him to another brother
and they were talking to him so
re-explain that he [ __ ] up he said
this and that and the other
and he was saying how oh i don't know
why that
like you man open the shop how can how
can how can they open a shop like you're
[ __ ] barbers you're [ __ ] barbers
how can you do this to my hair not
obviously he was talking to the guy
about his experience from another spot
so there's just pressure and it's just
me and this guy in the shop you know i'm
the only other customer
oh my god he's just kite in my hair just
there's about five men in a shop it's a
sunday afternoon
it's quiet man's causing a ruckus
mad as if to say he's asking for a
refund yeah if i was thinking surely
he's left in two weeks
and he's still got this fire in his
chest bro but anyways
ask me the question again i had to segue
ask me to ask you a question again
completely forgot the question
have you had if you ever had a bad
experience or do you remember any bad
experiences of obama
i probably have but yeah i think
my last one i remember yes i remember i
remember the last
bad experience because i made a funny
joke about it and you were up here it
was in money
it was when i first moved up here and i
was still living by myself
and i used to get a trim up in hume when
i used to live in hume yeah
um i met donnie wouldn't donny's fates
were inconsistent
like some fades would be like this some
phase would be high some fades would be
like it just wasn't i just and he was
charging me this was back
before this is when everyone was
charging 10
but he had changed to 12. okay so
i had to draws for a 20. i'm thinking oh
you're not even cutting my hair right
and and you're leaving me with coins in
my wallet and the brand next to him
was always good but i've always been
with this guy yeah i think it was one of
the ones i could just never go to him
there's only two of them in a shop yeah
um and i remember
i remember you were waiting for me
outside the gate or something and i was
like sorry i was jogging back and i was
like i'm sorry yeah
donny don't even try to cut my hair got
me looking like [ __ ] a sapphire power
do you remember
i remember exactly i didn't know that
whole story until you said a sapphire
what a context water
context that's hilarious you went to
grand pacific that day i remember
grabbing it yeah um
miso burger yeah i remember [ __ ] it out
yeah but defending things i didn't say
anything
of course not because you asked me that
question just reminded me of me
hearing someone else say something i was
like you've got a [ __ ] point you
should say something
i've never said anything but so yeah
answer your own question
i hope you're comfortable oh god
so i was thinking like obviously i was
out this is the this question resonated
with me because
this isn't something i've experienced
for a long time
okay until recently so basically
obviously you've seen my barber now and
you know the barbie dolls
so he's been cutting my hair since i was
13 14. he's been cutting for a long time
[ __ ] it out barbara see a lot of people
come and go fam
he's been coming for a long time he's
seen me since i was in school uniform oh
wow
now i'm big man so
he's seen me about it and i'm not gonna
lie to you
my hairline is not as strong as it was
14 years ago
i've got a little bit of light bits
coming in the corners it's neither here
nor there we can spray that
it's miner later don't catch her don't
don't you man don't get vexed like it's
fine
yeah don't think about it it's minus
minus mine you won't even notice
um but
anyway so we must have been he must have
been cutting my hair a little while ago
and i said to my man what are you doing
to my hairline as a joke
because he was peeling it back
flow bananas j cole peel that back he
was peeling it back and i was like
big man as a drug i said what are you
doing to my hair family why are you
peeing in the back so much
a man said off the cuff he's like you
know what your hairline's saying
you know your hairline saying so don't
come to me talking about why am i doing
i'm trying to help
so i was like listen listen listen
listen listen listen listen listen
listen
listen listen listen listen
listen lisa listen there's nothing wrong
with my airline cars
your talent is what's lacking don't come
to me
talking about genetics my hairline is
fresh
as the day i was born don't try it yeah
and he's like yeah
same same yeah from courses so i'm like
yeah whatever
believe in my own bravado my own smoke
my plans on holiday at the minute and so
i have to go to next prayer
next bread trimmed it and i've been to
him a couple of times i don't enjoy it
but obviously i do what i have to do
and i'm seeing the pieces that that
donnie's talking about
these little corners looking a bit light
in that the bits that he's
flow banana in peeling back and
he's not mama's not peeling it back okay
and i'm noticing and i'm thinking
maybe maybe here's my hairline
this guy is not doing the thing and i
remember there was a time last time i
come on
and i remember when i got here you were
like your hair's fresh yeah because my
my normal dog ain't done it yeah because
i started [ __ ] with the loaf eating
and i must have asked my man the new
donny low fade
couldn't patent it that's why i got this
hiding he could
not pattern it the first thing there was
a
significant difference it was like
1.5 zero and a little fuzz in
the middle no way to blend it i was like
this is not the one
this is not the one so anyway and i was
thinking about borrowing
i got home that night and i was thinking
about like just the stress of having to
to have these expectations of a barber
like what you just said like you open
the shop
you should be able to feel comfortable
just walking in and going to anyone
whoever's chairs for you jump in and you
do your that's the bare minimum
that's the bit it's literally the bear
man that should be the bare minimum
that's beyond maximum in the
afro-caribbean world yeah that's beyond
maximum
you only go to one or two guys max in a
month
if there's a check if there's a six if
it's a six chair barbershop if you go to
all six
you're claps i don't know what you're
doing you're getting a skin off
all your hair's coming off you can go to
all six no you don't care about it you
don't care about your hair you don't
care about your hair
so i was thinking about thinking about
it and for some reason it threw me back
like to my childhood
and i was thinking raw like my hair was
peaked for a long time when i was a
you know pee for a long time and i
remember my dad like so my
my for for contacts my dad has bothered
my
mother's hair is gone yeah so when i
lived in luton
my dad used to take us these african
barbers
and all i remember is they used to have
the the church channel
okay on repeat yeah all remember they
always had god
on the tv congolese i don't know okay i
was a youtuber
i barely knew what an african was all i
knew was black and white you know
i barely knew what an african was
at this age i mean you're live i'm being
serious
all i knew was black and white and mixed
me
that's too funny that's too funny i
barely knew what african was
so he had church going yeah
and i remember i used to tell my dad
[ __ ] so obviously i'm in primary school
and i'll say these times these men are
patterning
they're starting to sort out different
kind of cuts
so i'm seeing a couple night ticks and
stuff couple lines
yeah yeah yeah yeah swirly swell swirly
swirl bear zigzags
and i'm like that i want to be in a crew
in it so
i i missed you say to my dad on the way
he'd take us on a saturday when he pick
us up here pick us up from our moms take
us to the barbers
and i'm like dad right this is what i
want right i want this thing i didn't
know what fade was i didn't know what
the zigzag wasn't you know the line
wasn't him where the nighttick was
i knew when obviously an acting was so
i'm like yo listen i want the bit where
it's longer on top
and i want it to to come down and
shorter like here but i was like yeah
and i'm like and these men are coming it
looks like a night tick that you know a
night take like on a show
like i want that on my head back i want
that and
i said yeah cool take me to the bar but
my dad didn't give a single [ __ ]
took us to the barber and he's like yeah
in the ceiling seat
and then like um obviously i'm you know
me like i'm a socially
anxious person yeah and obviously it's
if you don't know me it's pretty much in
this
indistinguishable at this point like you
wouldn't know that i'm a socially
awkward person you just think i'm rude
if i'm not talking to you
yeah unless i'm in the mood then i'll
make the effort or if i feel like
i have to make the effort because like
of whatever like then you wouldn't even
notice but like obviously growing up i
was
it was obvious yeah when i was a little
kid yeah
so i'm saying to that like tell please
tell the guy that's what i want tell him
tell him he's like cool cool cool
we sit down i'm next my dad's like james
sit down and i'm like cool thinking my
dad's going to tell you about
it yeah he's going to tell him he's
going to tell him all the things
sit down and barbara's like yes young
man
now what do you want i'm looking at pops
like
wide-eyed like dad tell him what i want
man just said go on tell him
and i was like
i want um
i wanted to i want the thing was like
it's like a little bit
curly like i didn't know what a wave was
in it i want a little bit it's a little
bit curly on top
and just like here's a little bit curly
and then it it comes down
like i didn't know what fade was i
didn't know what skin fade was
terminology
i didn't know any of that i was like it
comes down
and then and then on the back it's like
a nick
like a nike like on the shoe like it's a
nike
on the back that's what i want
a man said cool story bro
shave the whole thing off one
all over no shape up
man says safe
god knows what you want
here's what i'm going to do but dad sat
there and found the whole thing
was it a punishment was that punishing
you for starting my dad just didn't
care he didn't listen to what i said
it's like the thing was coerced it's
like you [ __ ] up in school on a friday
this baba
every other weekend didn't give a single
[ __ ]
what i wanted every time i said what i
wanted to say cool story fam
yeah yeah safe i'm trying to connect
with god so if you could do me a favor
shut up firm this one all over no shape
up and then go to school and fend
for yourself for five more days
fend for yourself until your egg grows
back and we'll go for this song and
dance again oh my god that was my entire
childhood
oh my god it was peak it was
peak oh my god until my dad moved
as this is when i little luton and my
dad lived in lund so then my dad moved
out of loon
so there was no reason for my man to
take us to this barber anymore so then
my mom obviously had to take on the
responsibility
to take us to the barbers so i think she
took us to my man once or twice
and my brother hated that barbers he
would ball his eyes out
every time because he said it would hurt
him so obviously at this point my mum's
met
my step-dad who again black guy
and he abided just like my dad so um
she's about my stepdad and we're going
through the song and dance
this barber thing and then um
for some [ __ ] reason
we're sitting down one time talking
about haircuts
and my mother just has to pipe up and
it's like oh yeah
and i'm like all right these times all i
know is one all over
all i know is disrespect as far as it
comes with haircuts
so i've got no preference yeah whoever's
gonna murk my head top it doesn't matter
yeah
[Music]
he opens up his pack he's a little
leather pack
he's got all the clippers in there all
the other attachments and that
i'm like swear you probably can cut here
you ain't got [ __ ]
hair to say follicle to save his life
but whatever in it he can probably cut a
couple here
and then he's like cool so
i'll cut you here next week so next week
rose my hair grows back
is that cool my mom's like cool your
stepdad is going to cut your hair
and i'm like i bet sits me down
puts a towel around my neck i'm feeling
comfortable
a man says what do you want and i'm like
all right listen
listen i don't need the swirly sword i
don't need the ziggy zag
i don't need the nike tick just i just
want the curly curl on top
and i wanted to trickle down into the
short thing here
a man said bet i'm safe
i'm glistening in my teeth my teeth are
shiny yeah
i'm thinking yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
mine's about to roll into school
tomorrow fresh fresh a man said psych
one all over
no shape up same thing
same thing i've been going through fam
same thing i've
been going through my baby hairs were
draped on my forehead
i was tired of it and i was like alright
so this is
this is what a haircut is i don't know
any better
these men their hair must grow like that
because i've had separate adults
tell me that this is what i'm asking for
man i ordered glitz and glam and he's
giving me the same thing that african
don is giving me
so clearly this is what i'm asking for
separate adults
okay this is what i'm asking for this is
my punishment
for birth my mom's like oh that's
nice that's nice and i'm like shut up
so from two or three weeks go by
and we've had the same drapes out
haircut
week after week after week week after
week my little brother's
balling he hates the pain
and he hates facing the musical scuffer
he's sick of it and he's two years
younger than me and he's
tired of it yeah and what time
my mancus my mom calls us downstairs and
she's like yo
james lawrence come downstairs time to
get your trim
and i'm thinking whatever either just
kidding
a slave has been beaten down enough and
their scars run
deep yeah and they just firm they've
just accepted their lot in life
that's where i was at and this is just
the head top i've been
dealt with yeah this is it the year six
years that are rolling into school in
skirts and high socks
i won't be able to talk to them and
that's just where i'm at yeah
something i have to accept yeah so it's
cool
whoever trimmed my head top i've seen
enough
do what you have to do so i'm ready come
downstairs quick too
like do the thing my brother says no my
little brother says nah i'm not coming
downstairs
my mom's like let's get your ass
downstairs yeah man said nah i'm coming
down
and she's like what's wrong man said it
hurts and i said brother come on brother
don't hurt
her it's it's minor come on now and i'm
like yeah it doesn't hurt like
my eyes are black like i i don't i don't
know what love is yeah
i don't feel it anymore i don't feel
anything anymore i'm numb
i'm numb i said yeah yeah calm down fam
be dramatic i ain't coming downstairs
i promise you now i ain't going here
crying my hair
i'm bobbing cut my hair i'm telling you
this yeah
mom said get your ass downstairs now a
man came downstairs
watched me get my thing done and then
when it was his turn
man was crying already i'm sitting there
like
no no you must have said
my mom's like why why do you want to cut
yeah
i might say it hurts it hurts i'm not
doing it
these times i thought his head top was
hurting clearly it was his soul that was
right
i said it hurts i'm not doing it
yeah like he's not cutting my hair again
my mom was like you better shut your
mouth
or you don't know what her is
you bird drips towel round your neck
or you're gonna find out what hurt
really means
my man said bet he's sprinted upstairs
and the bathroom door slammed shut
and we was like what's going on my mom
came up and said she's
banging on the door she said let me in i
said nah
better than my man my man's like six
seven
yeah she's banging down the door she
said let me in i said nah
he ain't cutting my head fam
next thing i heard the the padlock
unlock whatever it's called the
thing slide and my mom's like
she's screaming she's screaming
and i'm like what's going on someone's
in danger yeah i found my sprint
upstairs i'm like what's going on my
little brother my head's draped baby has
drapes across my foot
a sprint upstairs
and my man's got blood trickling here
and here
and i said what's going on
my man
my mom's leg raiser and he shaved his
whole head
he's shaving his whole head
there was prickles galore bear patches
fam
blood everywhere a message humana never
got my egg yet
he said these [ __ ] never touching my
head
again
what a story fam have you never told me
that
it was the funniest thing it was the
funniest
thing my
so she ran my dad on the spot she said
take him to the barbers now i'm engaging
my mama's in the ballet i ain't going
barbless
my hair's trimmed leave me the [ __ ]
alone
oh please fam
[Laughter]
funniest thing that's the funniest thing
you've ever told me that's one of the
funniest stories you've ever talked
about oh
funny stories on this one top five
oh broth it was funny bro that's one of
the top five stories
[ __ ] that was funny ah that's when i got
my vigor again
that's when i got my figure again i was
like enough is enough that's taking my
breath away
from the coincidence the next year we
moved
up north to north hampton
we moved to northampton and my mom said
we're going barbers fam going barbers
this time by the time it took us
because it moves at easter holidays by
the time it took us to get there
settle in like find schools
find my mom find a job everything my
hair was here
long and she said taking your barbers
like now
so i started school for about two weeks
so we're going barbers
and i was terrified yeah of course
because you've got no other content fam
i've got new friends i've got another
context all i know is there's one up top
no shape up
so i said to my man man i said what do
you want when i got there i said listen
listen listen
just these men know me for this now yeah
just leave her eyes
just tidy it up leave it how it is
and then he was like calm move that's
what you want then find like i don't
understand why you would do that to
yourself but
miner man cleaned the thing up like i
was in the 70s
like the thing was microphone
quality ting shape up was fresh
and i was thinking blood cloth this is
the best i've ever looked
yeah i mean you're seven how many
seven my thing was shaped and i was like
you know this thing this bruno mustang
fam i felt peppered i was ready
every morning i was waking up this thing
i went in there with my freshest gums
the next day
and my shoulders were swaying
i was thinking these [ __ ] aren't
ready for what i'm about to bring to the
playground
oh femme i walked in i won donny
he was in my friendship called his name
was perry and uh i actually think he
listens to this he's commented before so
he might listen like now and again i
[ __ ] hope he has this
obviously i these man didn't understand
my whole life i didn't know what a cut
was
i didn't know what fade was even the one
all over i didn't know what the shape up
was i didn't know what the big bag
sideburns were
i don't know what pattern was i didn't
know none of this all i knew was the
supreme mandem
but treated correctly and i was given my
law in life
you had no choice so when i was given
this thing
i felt brand new i rolled in there
obviously every man had their own cuts
for the week
every man one and a half on top skin
fade
probably a couple patterns in there they
went to the same barber
and i was in there with my little mini
fry filling fresh
i found my rose to the playground before
school
i rolled in there thinking i'm ready for
the lavish
treatment i rolled in there first thing
perry's like
what's going on with ed i said what did
she mean
i thought the introduction yeah like
listen
what do you mean would you my head oh
you want to talk about my head
you must not be talking about yeah you
can't be talking about my head because
this
is this is fresh this is levish and i
had that oil sheen you know that spray
i had that he was glistening i was like
i can't imagine who's there i actually
whose head are we discussing yeah
because today
it's not mine because one of them was
like me and you look back bam i look
back twice
my collar open my eyes are like this
my pin pants are out loud
a man said wag one for your head top
because and i was like wait what what
what's this up
what's what b is in your bonnet
a man said he turned to his boys he
turned to
our boys and my mom was like
he hotten me up i must have in front of
the whole playground
he did this thing you know when the
chest is flying like
hey you man am i wearing barbers
this thing and i asked for mini fro
the color fell from my cheeks the color
dropped
from my cheeks you lost blood pressure
affirm
i lost blood pressure i was pale as a
ghost
because like even though i didn't
understand i understood that the term
mini fro
was derogatory
matt came with chess with this thing i
was like you man
man went barbers and asked for mini from
fam obviously the whole man bullying me
for weeks until it grew out
and then they they they catered to man i
was happy because this is when the
the crew came through it yeah and they
were like come come to our bar
you are gone come to above and from then
it was a wrap from then i was like
so this is the current barber you go to
now this no no no no
okay cool long story short i won't dwell
on it
the barber they took me to is an
alcoholic
i don't want to do it on it i don't want
to get into it the moment it took me two
is an alcoholic so it couldn't bang
long term it couldn't bank so i had to
lock my man off
and move to the guy that i'm with now so
when i was 14 i started going to this
new man
oh that's hilarious and i've been with
him ever since um
but yeah this is that's that's been a
long thing that's been a long run
so um guys just lock
do you want to lock it yeah man yeah so
guys we're gonna wrap it there
um we love you we do love you and we're
gonna we're gonna see you next week so
enjoy your week and um we'll see in a
few days actually
one morning but that's habit
that's throwing me for a loop i'm so
used to saying see you next week yeah
actually to be fair it's usually you to
say see you next week
next week i'll head out guys we'll see
you on the next episode
in three days we'll see you in a few
days like i i don't know where we're at
anymore yeah i can't keep up with this
we'll see you in a few days